hi there
my name is katie osberg and i lead
global retail partnerships for google's
new and exciting suite of business
communication products
today my colleague sean and i cannot be
more thrilled to share our most recent
launch google business messages
but before we dive into what our product
is or even how it works
it's helpful to understand why this
technology is so critical
as with all great tech evolutions the
solution often stems from a problem
and ours is no different so briefly
i'm going to ask you to put your user
hat on for a moment and humor me as i
pose a few questions
how many of you have experienced at
least one or more of the following
situations
over the last couple of months might you
have had to rebook
travel perhaps you remember the feeling
of going to multiple stores and still
not finding the product you were looking
for or could it be that you were working
from home
or perhaps your kids for completing
their e-learning course when suddenly
your internet went out in all those
situations
users needed to get in touch with brands
or businesses
but because there was an outreach spike
these critical connections were
seemingly impossible
almost every business was promoting on
either their website or answering
machine
that call volumes were up and wait times
were exceptionally long
few provided alternative means to get in
touch and resolution
at least in the manner that was
convenient say on the user's terms
seemed impossible now if i'm the
customer
when i hear exceptionally long wait
times i think
great this is going to take forever and
who has the time to wait on hold anymore
time and attention has become
increasingly more valuable
and while exacerbated by the global
pandemic this concept is not new
users are just simply pulled in too many
directions but the same can be said for
businesses now
in addition to the overwhelming demand
to speak to someone caused by the global
pandemic
it's no secret that businesses have also
been tasked with an influx of new
responsibilities
for example most are instituting new
health standards to keep employees safe
and many are adjusting operational
protocols to meet new
and evolving consumption behaviors
absolute user demands to diversify
interaction channels
businesses are going to have to rethink
the way they communicate with customers
such that interactions are more
meaningful result in resolutions
and ultimately drive connections that
count
now we at google understand that we're
often responsible for facilitating that
connection
between a user and a brand and over the
last 20 years
we've worked to perfect the art of
surfacing the right product
service and business in the moments that
matter
but as technology evolves we've come to
understand that surfacing a call button
or perhaps a link to a contact us page
might not be the most effective way for
us to facilitate this connection
in fact these connections can be
incredibly expensive for businesses
and extremely frustrating for users did
you know that businesses spend 1.3
trillion
on 265 billion customer service calls
each year
and 67 of people have raised their hand
indicating that they would rather
message a business
than speak with a person the
communication experiences of today
are expensive frustrating and frankly
inconvenient which is why users have
begun to demand
conversational messaging solutions not
just from google
but from their favorite brands and
businesses
to be successful in the space it has
become abundantly clear
that three things must be true about
your messaging experiences
they must be asynchronous enabling users
to pick up and exit the conversation
at their convenience automated returning
responses
to users in real time and finally
assistive helping users to determine
which products or services
are right for them today as a result of
these learnings
we couldn't be more excited to share how
we've evolved the google search
experience
to facilitate making connections that
count over to you sharon
thanks kiggy my name is sean faulconer
and i lead developer relations for
google's
business communication products and i'm
going to take you through our
conversational solution business
messages so what exactly is business
messages
business messages let your customers
message your business directly
from your search and maps results as
katie described
many business conversations begin on a
google service like search or maps
and until recently customers are both
calling your business for support or
digging through your website to find the
correct means to contact you
with business messages you can provide
customers high quality help
through your search and maps results
instead of a customer being
redirected to your phone system or
website they will see a message button
where they can begin a conversation with
your business
so how do you go about creating a
conversational experience for your
business with business messages
let's take a look
as a consumer your customer user journey
begins as it does today
by searching for that business on google
search once you find the business you're
trying to contact
instead of only seeing call directions
and website buttons
a business enabled with business
messages will also have a message button
tapping on the message button will
launch a conversational surface
where you can begin chatting with that
business these conversations can begin
on an ios or android device
behind the scenes what is happening is
messages sent from consumers
are passed through the business messages
api through to a messaging partner or
your business directly
via configured web hook once you receive
the message you can pass that message to
a live or digital agent
this diagram shows this process in a
little more detail the user or consumer
begins on search of maps
looks up a business opens a conversation
with that business
is greeted with a customized welcome
message and begins a conversation
messages from the consumer are passed
through the northbound api
and push your webhook as a json object
the webhook parses the received object
that contains the consumer's message
the preferred language of the user
timestamp information
a unique conversation id in the
consumer's display name
within your web hook you can write that
message to a digital agent as your first
line of defense for handling common
customer support issues
or pass the conversation over to a live
agent to handle more complex user
journeys
business messages helps you leverage the
existing user behavior to contact your
business through search your maps
where you can continue to take advantage
of the discovery and reach of these
products
while providing a more direct way for
you to have real
and meaningful personalized
conversations with your consumers
the business messages platform and api
supports rich features like cards
carousels suggestion chips photos and
actions
that help you deep link into your
website or app by utilizing these rich
features
you can create an engaging user journey
to capture leads
sell products or solve customer support
issues
combining the discovery and reach of
your business on search
along with the rich features i just
imagined in automation through a digital
agent
you can help your consumers solve
customer issues without the cost of a
phone call or live agent
like with an app or website the business
messages rich
features help you direct the user
through a supported user journey that
can be fully automated
digital agents can be created using
tools like google cloud's dialogflow
our tool for creating agents that
understand natural language
companies like walmart have used
dialogflow to not only power their
digital agent on business messages
but also automate a large majority of
customer support inquiries
leaving their live agents available to
handle more complex and
unique requests
business messages is an innovation in
creating true customer connections
the rich features of the platform help
you put guardrails around your automated
experiences so you can steer your
consumers through a happy path to solve
problems
but outside of the fancy features this
is a conversational platform
your customer is conversing directly
with your business
utilizing tools like dialogflow help you
to automatically respond quickly and
naturally to customers regardless of the
time of day
or current load on your live agents the
combination of a natural entry point
from search the rich user interface and
the powerful automation
provided by tools like dialogflow
represent a true technological
innovation
in fact we see these major shifts in how
consumers interact with technology and
businesses every 10 years or so
back in the 70s we had mainframes in the
80s we had desktop competing
in the mid-90s the internet and then in
the mid-august mobile and smartphone
revolution
it's now hard to imagine a world today
without a smartphone
we're all walking around with a small
computer in our pocket this would have
been unheard of 20 years ago but it
completely changed how your consumers
interact with your business
you had to adapt to creating an app for
your business redesigning your website
to adapt to smartphone screen sizes
and now i believe the next shift is
happening is around ai
messaging and personalized rich
conversations business messages is
google's solution
to help your business adapt to this
technological evolution
all right let's take a look at a couple
real world examples
this first demo is from walmart who is
live with business messages for some
other locations in the united states
they deployed a digital agent first
experience where they use dialogflow to
create a conversational agent that can
address common customer support issues
like opening senior hours coveted 19
protocols
and looking up store locations their
business messages webhook
is using node.js to call the dialogflow
apis to power the digital agent
they did a lot of iteration on their
automation reviewing
where the original dialogflow agent was
enabled to help
and made iterative improvements they're
now handling the majority of customer
support requests
through their automation let's take a
look at their experience
let's begin our journey to speak to my
local walmart the google search
so i look up walmart san jose and show a
few different potential locations
i choose the walmart supercenter that i
know and see the local listing result
to begin my chat experience i tap on
message which opens a conversational
overlay
with this specific walmart i see a
customized welcome message
letting me know what this chatbot can
help me with i choose to agree to
continue my conversation
once the chatbot receives my
acknowledgement my conversation with the
digital agent begins
from the greeting i can see a chip list
with the various types of user journeys
the chatbot supports things like hiring
pickup times inventory
hours store safety and so on there's
really a lot that chatbot can help me
with
i'm going to choose store hours when i
choose this item
the request is being sent back through
the business messages api
to the walmart web hook and then the web
hook is sending this request to
dialogflow
to computer response based on the query
and in this case a specific walmart
location that i asked about
because this is a chat interface i can
also just type in the request
so i'm going to ask do i have to wear a
mask once i hit send
the same process to handle this message
through walmart's digital agent will be
carried out
and we can see that since july 20th all
shoppers have to wear a mask
this is super helpful i'm going to ask
one more question
this time i ask is there a limit to how
many people can be in the store at once
once walmart receives this request they
respond letting me know that they're
taking measures to promote social
distance
and they include a link out to read more
about these measures
so with the walmart's business messages
experience i was able to find out the
hours
and the kovid 19 protocol requirements
from my local store
all without having to wait to speak to a
live agent or dig through the walmart
website for the information
because walmart is leveraging dialogue
in this experience i can also have a
natural conversation with the bot
which is really really amazing the
second demo is from wolvers
australia's largest supermarket chain
like walmart they use dialogflow to
create a digital agent-first approach
they put a lot of their company's
personality in the automation
following conversational design best
practices such as starting with a
persona
creating a unique voice and example
dialogue
besides handling simple questions and
answers the agent also helps customers
look up inventory within their local
wars
let's take a look at their demo
as with walmart i begin my woolworth's
chat experience with a google search for
a local location
this time in sydney directly within the
search results i see the location i'm
looking for
and i can tap on the message button i
see that i am talking to all of
wolvers virtual assistant and there are
some conversational starters i can use
to begin my conversation
i'm going to start by trying to find a
product olive prompts me from the
product
and i'm going to try to find hand
sanitizer something that we all likely
need right now
olive is looking at the query and does a
great job of setting expectations about
the stock levels
my results for the specific store come
back in a carousel
and i can see that although the first
brand is out of stock there is another
brand available
and in fact it's even available in il14
i know my local store has hand sanitizer
i'm going to search for another product
by simply typing in i'm also looking for
tim tams
one of my favorite australian treats the
same process is carried out
where all is going to understand my
question and look up the stock levels
for this specific store
and product once my results are returned
i see that there are stock available in
a few different flavors and they are
available in aisle 9.
now that i know what i need is available
i'm going to look up the location store
hours so i know when i can pick up my
hand sanitizer and tim tams
looks like most stores are back on
regular hours all
returns both the store hours for the
location i was interested in
as well as others close by so that i
have a few different options
i can also see that there is more
information available to the store
locator
which is an action that deep links in
the worst website where i can get more
information about the store location
this woolworth's business messages
chatbot is live across locations in
australia
the real time inventory lookup is a
powerful experience for customers
saving us potentially unnecessary trips
to the store
those are just two examples of existing
experiences on business messages today
there are many other customer journeys
that you can potentially create on the
platform for your business
to talk about the future of messaging
i'm going to pass this back to katy
thank you very much thanks sean
it's natural that users will not only
expect this technology but eventually
demand it from their favorite brands and
businesses
and as this happens you'll start to see
a natural evolution in the
sophistication of these conversations
today these conversations may be limited
to simple faqs in the pursuit of fast
easily accessible information in a
streamlined format
but they too should be sophisticated
enough to serve as appropriate
contextual information
let's take a look at an example meet
dash bridgeport runners virtual
assistant in this example you'll see
that i've asked
when my store opens in the morning and
he promptly returns 7 30 am
he also addresses my curbside pickup
inquiry and finishes by asking if
there's anything else i need help with
now again the back and forth here is
mainly faq driven
but even within the language dash uses
for example
it sure is you feel his eagerness which
is in line with our persona best
practices
sean touched on earlier the next
evolution we can expect to see with
these experiences
is consultative discussions this can
lead to conversational commerce or even
assisted decision making
for example determining which department
you'll need to be connected with before
handing off the experience to a skilled
live agent
in the upcoming example you'll see that
dash has the ability to take customer
contacts
make calculated recommendations and
finally facilitate conversational
commerce
all within the confines of a
frictionless chat let's take a look
in response to anything else i can help
with i let dash know that i'm running a
5k
and ask him for shoe recommendations
with his enthusiastic attitude
dash quickly returns a handful of shoes
that suit my needs
once stash confirms that the product i'm
looking for is in fact available
i promptly am deep linked to the website
to transact here
you'll notice that my store and curbside
have already been pre-selected making my
checkout process
infinitely easier then within the
messaging experience
i'm past the appropriate tracking
information and notified of my order is
ready to be picked up
pretty cool right finally we looked at
the future of this technology
we fully expect that come 2021 or maybe
even late 2020
marketing teams will be building
conversational strategies into their
immediate plans
this is because these conversational
experiences enable brands to build
loyalty
and maintain one-to-one relationships
with their users ultimately increasing
the overall lifetime value
of their existing customer base
personalization will reach new heights
as contextual information is used to
reach out to customers
in new and assistive ways let's take a
look
in this final example you'll see that
dash has reached back out to me
not only to see how my training's been
going but also to ensure i like my new
shoes
he then surfaces many helpful options
including running content
other products i may need as well as 5k
tips
when i click through on the running
content chip you'll see that i passed a
running techniques video
that could be incredibly useful as i
prepare for the upcoming race
what's unique about this experience is
that dash didn't ask for the sale
he didn't even push me any promotions he
focused on the user
and was able to connect with me in a way
that few brands can
as we look to the future that is
conversational marketing ask yourself
are you ready for today tomorrow and the
future of messaging
if your answer is yes we'd love to get
you on boarded
if your answer is no that's okay too
it's not too late to build an effective
strategy
and should you have any questions we're
here to help
if you'd like to learn more about google
business messages please take a look at
our website and be sure to fill out the
interest form
from all of us on the business
communications team thank you for your
time
and we look forward to hearing from you